I got in this car was in a great move
now listen I'm like I'm against babies
most of its cuz I have a temper the
other part is I don't leave enough time
and then like the other like I don't
know 40% of it is that people suck at
driving I don't think I'm the greatest
driver but you know what I am
considerate but walking in the crosswalk
hustle ah they got that he always can
eat you know a woman goes by and she's
got the heels on well you know what he's
supposed to do can't run on their tippy
toes like Walter Payton did although
Walter Payton ran on his tiptoes his
whole [ __ ] career he never got an
injured look at that guy tell me that
guy didn't know where Whitey Bulger was
all these years
watch this guy watch this [ __ ]
[ __ ] the one pedestrian out here
right when I want to make a left
look at this [ __ ] guy on his phone
walk in as slow as you can as long as
you can
I always jog in the crosswalk alright I
get across
I do the wave now what's that guy he's
got the rainbow boots
oh yeah oh okay I thought those were
pants he actually has a tan his pants
his legs in the same color is he
supposed to be the Reno 911 guy who's
having more fun than this guy you know I
think of every cop dressed that way and
like there would be no more [ __ ]
violence you know what I mean
guy just come up sorry okay you're going
a little fast big guy how you doing
sweetie pie you seem just giving the
thumbs-up to the fire department I
[ __ ] love that guy I just got me in a
good mood